your home was burglarized this year is
that true yes
did I just remind you yes because you
seemed unsure that it was really
something that happened you know it's
been a weird year because it was a very
interesting burglary um
what one my home burned down right I'm
sorry so I had to stay I was staying and
everything home burned down I can't go
up ya know so in Malibu so I so I was at
first I was a bit sorts and I stayed at
a friend's house in Beverly Hills and
they were they were gone they were out
of town so I was staying at their house
and then I had to leave town too and I
got a call one day saying are you I'm do
you have a friend staying at the house
and I said no I don't I don't think so
for its lucky I'm staying at those I
don't think I'd be inviting anybody else
and they said because there's somebody
downstairs in the shower and they're and
they're taking this long shower later
that day and then I forget about it and
later that day I see somebody's trying
to change my passcode and I get in touch
with my tech guy and he says that's code
on my computer or my phone I think I
call my tech guy he says yeah he said
I'm we're replacing your phone because
it was stolen when the house was broken
into today I'm like wait wait what
what's what happened
so it then find out and nobody had
bothered to tell me right I think they
were trying to sort it all out and hope
they could but a guy had gotten into the
house he's the house that you're staying
in is a glass house that I was saying as
yes but they were gone for quite a while
yeah he he takes a 45-minute shower
smokes a bunch of weed because
apparently when they went in that there
was a housekeepers went down to find out
what was going on they the place stunk a
weed he he took a 45-minute shower came
out and didn't really want to confront
him so he took some of my Chloe took a
t-shirt and a pair of pants like he's
very clean Burghley we didn't want to
get back in the same cloak left his
clothes there eat a banana put the
banana peel in the dog bowl had a
granola bar took a phone took my bicycle
so he could leave and left so it was
very efficient
I do like that he's he's getting his
carbs you know he's getting a piece
he's eating prop that sounded like a
good snack there's a so much sugar level
isn't it yeah he was very healthy I mean
he smoked weed but and he was obviously
hungry after smoking we had the munchies
so he one second Ricola bar I am and and
and that was that was that so yet didn't
but I also had a mobile home store and a
bunch of wait you're on mobile home was
nobody told me about I heard that until
I was being worked on I just bought it
and so he was being done up and then it
and then I find out through TMZ but it's
been stolen was anybody gonna tell me
this oh we weren't gonna tell you but we
were hoping to get it back wait a TMZ
guy comes up to you and says are you
aware that your mobile homes been stolen
no they called my publicist of my
publicist called me said TMZ want a
statement from you on your stolen mobile
home what stolen TMZ calls me you know
my office all the time it says Conan
supposed to pick his kid up in 20
minutes they're very I find them to be
very helpful
so anyway did you get your I hope you
got your home back I got it I got my
home bike the burgos gone
I don't even actually I have too many
t-shirts so I couldn't even work out
which one he took so I think I'm okay he
took the one that says I am Gerard
[Laughter]